let's go next to our caller from the
eight one six area code who's calling
today from eight one six yes I can
my name's Trey I'm 18 years old
and I don't necessarily fit the mold of
a typical progressive I'm actually a
moderate and I wanted to hear your
thought process on this we talked about
Bernie Sanders inability to win over
black voters like myself and more
moderate voters right yes so and what we
on the South was the second time he has
the wind blow the black voters not the
older so if you believe that black
voters and I don't know this for sure
but deep if you believe that black
voters are an important portion of a
Granik electorate then is it true that
even though Biden is no progressive he
is he has a base then Bernie does which
was one of the arguments of Bernie's
about why you should vote for him the
city discuss about all sorts of voters
and in build this giant tenth of a
electorate in order to defeat Donald
Trump in the hall well I don't I mean
listen from a personal standpoint of
course I think black voters are
important as I mean listen I don't want
to write off any portion of the
electorate every portion of the
electorate is important but I don't
think we need to speculate about you
know there's Biden have a bigger base by
virtue of having more black support
Biden got way more votes in the primary
so from the perspective of the
Democratic primary even before Bernie
dropped out Biden was winning by around
1.8 1.9 million votes so I mean Biden
won because he had more people
supporting him I I guess I don't need I
don't feel the need to hypothesize about
whether it's specifically because of
black black voters Trump but Biden had
way more make way more voters in the
primary when it comes to Biden versus
Trump it looks like about 92% of black
voters right now are supporting Biden
and we can
slice and dice it in other ways but your
there's no question that Biden had more
support that's why he won the primary
yeah I just I wanted to understand that
because you know I talked to some people
and I always tell them you know if you
look at the primary where we reach the
last Super Tuesday before Bernie dropped
out I've watched him your videos and you
talked about how oh my god okay I'm
gonna have to let you go you it looks
like you you just cut out there